hello my name is Charles and today we're
going to be playing a little game it is
my pleasure to introduce you to today's
episode of truth or fail English edition
hmm I am going to tell you two english
related facts one of them would be true
and one of the gloomy thoughts and it is
up to you the viewer to guess which one
is true there is no prize for winning so
there is really no point in playing but
if you're a bit bored or don't have the
ability to do anything but click on
things this is the game for you so I
tell people what to do this character
anymore I'm sorry right hello it was me
all along
ah there are lots of other episodes of
truth or fail or themed and as the
English one I've been given the task of
doing the English face questions where I
hope you have fun and I hope you learn
something along the way as well it's
always good to have fun and learning at
the same time Frank's number one the
name of the cricketing competition the
ashes comes from the urn uses of trophy
which contains the actual ashes of the
burns critical or number two if a whale
is found washed up on an English beach
its head belongs to the king click on
one of these it's your job to click on
one of these diver that one or that one
one of the two do you do click on one of
them it's your job or you don't have to
if you don't want to but I would like it
if you did so I have to stop doing this
ooba-dooba do click on one of these Jupe
Jupe do click on one of these fine you
have to click on anything if you don't
want to I hate you